und über die letzte Generation Menschen
die sich festkleben jetzt auch vom
Elbtunnel zum Beispiel in Hamburg und so
wie stehen Sie dazu
haben sie müssen genau das tun weil ich
will nicht in der Welt leben wo junge
Menschen das Gefühl haben ich muss diese
Art von Aktion machen die vielleicht
meine eigene körperliche Gesundheit
gefährdet die mich auf jeden Fall viel
Hass und Ärger irgendwie aussetzt weil
wir haben Politikerinnen und Politiker
die stehen in der Verantwortung nicht
nur für die vier Jahre diese gewählt
wurden und für die Menschen diese
gewählt haben sondern dafür tatsächlich
auch die Lebensgrundlagen zukünftiger
Generationen zu sichern und das nicht
nur Menschen das Gefühl haben diese
Politik tut nicht genug sondern das
wissenschaftlich erwiesen dass die
Politik tut nicht genug und das bräuchte
viel viel energischeres handeln das ist
erschreckend dass Menschen damit genau
diese Art von Aktion brauchen und ich
glaube es braucht diese Vielstimmigkeit
von Aktion immer wir hätten in jeder
zivilgesellschaftlichen Bewegung breites
Reparatur an Protestformen die auch
nicht immer alle legal waren um eben das
Frauenwahlrecht zu erreichen den
Atomausstieg Bürgerrechte für Schwarz in
den USA all das gab es nur durch breiten
Proteste auch nicht immer nur
Freude strahlenthin genommen wurde ja
das muss auch wehtun das ist gar keine
Frage wenn wir jetzt über Nachhaltigkeit
sprechen gibt eine interessante zahl ich
glaube sie haben sie irgendwo mal
erwähnt für 71 Prozent der weltweiten
Emissionen sind nur 100 Konzerne
verantwortlich das muss man sich auf der
Suche gehen lassen und allein Shell ist
ungefähr der Ölmulti Shell für 10% der
weltweiten Emissionen verantwortlich das
sind gesicherte Zahlen ja
welche Verantwortung erwächst daraus
ich glaube diese Zahlen zeigen als
allererstes vor allem welche
Verantwortung von der wir
gesellschaftlich immer glauben dass wir
sie hätten nicht in dieser Form
existiert dass diese sehr sehr
neoliberale wir können uns alle schaffen
deswegen können wir alle ganz ganz
alleine die Klimakrise aufhalten indem
wir noch eine bambuszahnbürste kaufen
eben nicht greift
sondern es gibt natürlich
Konsumentscheidungen die können wir
treffen und die sind wichtig und sie
summieren sich natürlich über eine
Gesellschaft als Ganzes aber was wir
hier auch schon vorhin gehört haben es
ist eine Frage von Infrastruktur wer
kann sich überhaupt für was entscheiden
wenn es kein öffentlichen Nahverkehr
gibt dann kann man sich gar nicht für
die klimafreundlichere Art der
Fortbewegung entscheiden wenn man
beispielsweise auf dem Land wohnt wenn
erneuerbaren Energien nicht ausgebaut
werden können dann kann man irgendwann
quasi kein Ökostrom mehr beziehen weil
so lange da das stockt so lange die
politischen Regularien das nicht
erlauben und geht das eben nicht und das
zeigt noch mal dass die Verantwortung
eben mehr ist als einzelverantwortung
bei irgendwie den Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern was uns so oft erzählt wird
sondern dass sie jedem systemisches
Problem haben was auch systemische
Lösungen braucht die wie bei einer Frage
von wie regulieren wir Wirtschaft wie
regulieren wir gerade die sehr sehr
emissionsintensiv intensiven Industrien
wie regulieren wir auch die Bereiche die
wir als Gesellschaft natürlich brauchen
Energieversorgung Wärmeversorgung nicht
ohne Grund haben wir Bildungen wird die
Bildung durch den Staat übernommen und
lagern wir sind nicht eben nur an
Privatschulen aus weil dann könnten sich
am Ende nur ein paar reiche Bildung
leisten und das glaube ich zeigt sich
eben genau mit solchen Zahlen noch mal
sehr sehr gut dass es nicht was es was
wir alle irgendwie einzelne lösen können
und beim Thema Verantwortung
Versandhaus kommt ein großer
Online-Händler ins Spiel Frau Hartmann
sie haben man interessantes Buch gemacht
die grüne Lüge 2018 da gibt es eine
wahnsinnszahl darin pro Jahr werden
weltweit was weiß Auto wie viele
Kleidungsstücke werden jedes Jahr
weltweit hergestellt was würden sie
schätzen
oh das würde ich sagen 100 Milliarden
paar 100 Milliarden ist gut es sind 100
Milliarden ungefähr ne es sind
mittlerweile ich habe es halt noch mal
nachgeschaut weil es ein Buch war eine
Zahl von 2015 glaube ich mittlerweile
sind 120 Milliarden
jedes Jahr weltweit hergestellt werden
so die Hälfte davon aus Baumwolle ja und
während nur ein Prozent dieser Baumwolle
ökologisch angebaut wird werden 70%, mit
Baumwollpflanzen hergestellt die
gentechnisch verändert sind und kommt
noch besser mit ihm steht 8000
Pestiziden
daraus wird unsere wenn unsere Klamotten
gemacht daraus werden unsere Klamotten
gemacht da kommt noch Plastik dazu dass
aus Erdöl gemacht wird weil die Kleider
die Textilindustrie immer schneller in
schnellerer folgekollektionen anbietet
das geht umso schneller wenn man das mit
Plastik macht weil das billiger und
schneller verfügbar ist es kommt die
unglaubliche Wasserverschwendung dazu
bei der Produktion von den
Kleidungsstücken und natürlich beim
Baumwollanbau die Herstellung eines
einzigen T-Shirts verschlingt stimmt das
2700 Liter Wasser
und eine Jeans 8000 Wasser
gutes Wasser gutes Wasser ja
wenn man sich beispielsweise anschaut
den Aralsee der so gut wie ausgetrocknet
ist das gilt ja als eine der größten
menschengemachten Umwelt Katastrophen
das ist durch den Anbau genau durch
usbekische Baumwolle entstanden und das
sind ganz gruselige Bilder und zu diesen
120 Milliarden Kleidungsstücken die pro
Jahr hingestellt werden kommen ja dann
noch mal die vier Millionen Tonnen
Altkleider dazu das heißt es sind
weltweit so viele Kleidungsstücken
Umlauf wie die ganze Menschheit niemals
auftragen können wird und da sind wir
zum einen als als einzelne
Konsumentinnen und Konsumenten irgendwie
auch an eine Grenze angelangt weil wir
natürlich alle sagen können ich kaufe
gar nicht so viel oder ich kaufe das
nicht mehr aber es wird trotzdem
hergestellt und es wird in immer
schnellere Geschwindigkeit hergestellt
und immer schneller weggeworfen weil und
das ist das grundsätzliche Problem und
da hat auch die
Unternehmensverantwortung natürlich ihre
Grenzen weil es keine moralische Frage
Frauen an den politischen ist der kann
kein Unternehmen sagen oh okay wir hören
auf das herzustellen weil dann werden
keine Profite mehr gemacht auf der
anderen Seite können Sie natürlich nur
gemacht werden auf diese Art und Weise
wenn man Zugriff hat auf billige
Rohstoffe und im Falle der
Textilindustrie natürlich auch billige
Arbeitskräfte andere Zahl im Kopf weiß
aber nicht ob die stimmt die
Textilindustrie der zweitgrößte CO2
Emittent oder drittgrößter also sehr
bezahlt es ist sehr weit vorne und da
ist eben Plastik auch ein Grund dafür
eben weil es Erdöl basiert ist und es
kommt noch dazu das wird ja jetzt gerade
jetzt erst so bekannt dass durch dadurch
dass das für die Altkleider gar kein
Markt mehr gibt und dass diese Kleider
der fast fashion also dieser wirklichen
in zwei Wochen hergestellt und schnell
verkauften wirklich minderwertigen
Kleidungsstücke dass man die gar nicht
mehr verwerten kann ich habe heute die
Zahl gelesen dass ein Drittel der
Kleidungsstücke gar nicht mehr
wiederverwertet werden kann die muss
also entsorgt werden oder Putzlumpen
gemacht und bei diesen und die werden
dann beispielsweise exportiert nach
Kenia oder nach Chile und werden dort
verbrannt also da werden die
plastikkleider verbrannt und deswegen
ist es auch so ein großer Klimaschaden
auch dadurch also es ist insgesamt schon
eine sehr sehr schädliche Industrie ja
die Frage ist sie haben wann haben Sie
angefangen sozusagen sich wirklich
ernsthaft für das Thema ich weiß doch in
unserem Gespräch vor 13 Jahren ging es
auch viel genau darum
Nachhaltigkeit Ökologie Zerstörung der
Umwelt Zerstörung der Ressourcen wann
haben Sie angefangen sich wirklich
ernsthaft damit auseinanderzusetzen und
warum
also im Grunde für mich war der Weckruf
damals 1972 der Erstbericht eine
klapperführung Grenzen des Wachstums und
ich habe mich damals dann auch sehr
intensiv unterhalten mit meinem Freund
Eduard Pestel mitbegründetes Klapper
froms und habe gesagt es ist toll das
ist ein Buch was Bewusstsein schafft
aber ich habe auch gesagt noch wichtiger
ist das Verhandeln und im Grunde muss
jeder bei sich selbst anfangen und ich
natürlich als Unternehmer muss auch bei
mir anfangen und habe dann angefangen
die 70er Jahren mit einzelnen Projekten
dass wir unsere Kartonage aus Altpapier
gefertigt haben dass wir unseren Katalog
der war nebenbei gesagt der erste
Katalog weltweit auf Chlor freien Papier
das heißt
Einzelprojekte bei uns im Unternehmen
1986 habe ich dann aber Umweltschutz
nachhaltiges Handeln zu Unternehmensziel
erklärt und in den 90er Jahren Beginn
der 90er Jahre habe der angefangen sie
ist mathematisch und das Sortimente zu
überarbeiten heißt im Blick auf
Nachhaltigkeit
auf Umweltverträglichkeit in zweiten
Hälfte der der 19 Jahre der Himmel auf
sozialstandard können Sie jetzt mal
konkret machen Stichwort Nachhaltigkeit
also was bedeutet das für ein Konzern
wie Otto der vor allen Dingen genau auch
von diesen Kleidungsstücken ganz massiv
lebt das heißt sie sind wenn Sie so
wollen Teil dieser Maschinerie und Teil
auch dieser dieses ökologischen Thema ob
sie wollen oder nicht richtig und
deswegen haben wir natürlich auch eine
Verantwortung dafür also wir haben
Anfang der 90er Jahre
angefangen mal unsere textilsortimente
anzuschauen ich dachte es gibt irgendwo
da schon eine Untersuchung um die
Umweltauswirkungen an der
Textilproduktion in jeder Stufe
letztendlich zu wissen gab es nicht wir
haben Studien mit Universitäten
gemeinsam angefertigt vom Baumwollanbau
über die verschiedenen Veredelungsstufen
und haben festgestellt in jeder Stufe
sind natürlich erheblich negative
Umweltauswirkungen beim Baumwollanbau
der hohe Wasserverbrauch Pestizide
richtig dann natürlich bei der Färberei
bei der Ausrüstung bei der Fertigung
aber wir haben auch festgestellt in
jeder Stufe gibt es durchaus die
Möglichkeiten es umweltverträglicher
herzustellen wir haben damals angefangen
dann in der Türkei die Baumwolle auf
biologischen Anbau umzustellen haben
baumwollfahrer gefördert wir haben
angefangen statt schwermetallhaltige
Farben in der bei dem biologisch
abbaubare Farben zu nehmen statt
Chlorbleiche ozonbleiche und und und und
und haben in jeder Stufe natürlich
zusammen mit der ganzen Lieferkette dann
eben die Produktion überarbeitet im
Hinblick auf umweltverträglichere
Produktion und waren stolz als wir dann
ja natürlich die erste Textilien hatten
bis wir schrittweise dann auf 100%
unserer eigenen Textilien die wir selbst
oder in Lizenzfertigung bei uns haben
und wir haben heute Baumwolle ist ein
ganz entscheidendes Thema das ist die
wichtigste Phase im Textilbereich wir
haben heute
praktisch fast 100 Prozent unserer
eigenen Sortimente wo wir nachhaltige
Baumwolle einsetzen und das ist im Wesen
das ist Biobaumwolle aber auch Baumwolle
konnten mit den Afrika das ist eine
Stiftung die ich vor 16 Jahren gegründet
habe wo wir afrikanische
Kleinbauern und Bäuerinnen Schulen in
besseren Anbautechniken und in
nachhaltigen Antwort Technik besser
haben und höre Einkommen haben und
nachhaltig in dem Blick auf Umweltschutz
auf Sozialstandards keine Kinderarbeit
und Umweltschutz sieht so aus dass die
Baumwolle die wir heute fertigen
völkisch im Vergleich zur herkömmlichen
traditionellen Baumwolle
pro Kilogramm Baumwolle
1800 Liter weniger Wasser hat das heißt
wir brauchen genau zwei Liter Wasser
wären sonst 1800 Liter pro Kilogramm
Baumwolle gebraucht wird wir haben CO2
17% wenig jetzt für zwei ausstoßen
teilweise in einzelnen Ländern bis 40
Prozent finanzfallschutz wir sind heute
in elf afrikanischen Ländern und haben
und eine Million Baumwoll Bäuerinnen und
Baumwoll Bauern in die Programme drin
und das ist dann natürlich schon wenn
man auch entsprechende Auswirkungen hat
und das ist die Baumwolle die wir
natürlich auch hier stand bei uns
einsetzen aber die auch andere
Einzelhändler Produzenten
überzeugt sie das sie waren ja viel
unterwegs ne haben viele recherchiert
weltweit auch haben sich
Produktionsbedingungen angeguckt haben
sich vor allen Dingen beschäftigt mit
diesem genau diesem Wort nachhaltigkeit
ist ja so ein Inflation mittlerweile
das klingt sehr überzeugend was Otto
hier vorträgt die Frage ist ist das der
Weg ist das ein überzeugender weg oder
ist das sozusagen möglicherweise der
Anfang von etwas was noch viel viel
größer werden muss also wenn ich von von
grünen Lügen spreche oder oder den
Begriff Greenwashing verwendet dann
meine ich natürlich nicht dass das alles
ausgedacht ist das Unternehmen einfach
was behaupten was sie da nicht machen
sondern es gibt diese Projekte ja
es gibt tatsächlich auch an Cotton made
in Africa Kritik dass es eben nicht Bio
Baumwolle ist weil eben trotzdem
Pestizide verwendet werden in Sambia
beispielsweise sind
Baumwoll Bauern und Bäuerinnen aus dem
Projekt ausgestiegen weil sie damit
nicht genug Geld verdient haben die
bauen jetzt so ja an für große Konzerne
zum Teil da gab es eine Untersuchung vor
ein paar Jahren das kann natürlich immer
ein Schritt sein so etwas was etwas
besser macht aber das grundsätzliche
Problem bleibt ja das ist einfach
möglicherweise in einer Nische bleibt
während einfach das Grohe an Kleidern
ich sage jetzt gar nicht sondern das
Büro an Kleider gekauft werden kann oder
verkauft wird eben nicht aus so einer
Produktion stammt und es ist eben oft so
und das sage ich jetzt auch ganz
allgemein das Projekt von Unternehmen
die möglicherweise einfach einen kleinen
Teil des Sortiments ausmachen da gibt es
da dann eine neue motorerscheinung ist
zum Beispiel dieses ozeanplastik
Kleidungsstücke aus Ozean Plastik das
macht dann einen klitzekleinen Teil bei
einem Unternehmen aus während das andere
aber zu herkömmlichen Bedingungen
hergestellt wird ich glaube ganz einfach
dass freiwillige
Unternehmensverantwortung jedes
Unternehmen hat natürlich immer einen
gewissen Spielraum also auch ein
Unternehmen wie die wie die Auto Group
kann sagen wir
bekennen unseren verpflichten uns dazu
beispielsweise in den Fabriken eine
Existenzsicherung zu zahlen sowas ist
alles denkbar oder
bestimmte Abkommen zu unterzeichnen das
hat Auto gemacht nach einer Plaza auch
aber grundsätzlich gehört es einfach
reguliert weil es nicht im einzeln
überlassen werden kann sich zwischen
Dingen zu entscheiden zwischen
Ausbeutung und nicht Ausbeutung da würde
ich sagen da müssen wir die Frage
einfach umdrehen nicht was soll ich
kaufen sondern warum ist es überhaupt
legal dass Dinge die mit Umwelt
Zerstörung und Ausbeutung verbunden sind
in den Supermarktregalen stehen warum
wird die Verantwortung auf mich
abgewälzt warum gibt es da nicht etwas
woran sich alle halten müssen und sowas
haben wir ja jetzt wenn auch noch nicht
ausgereift genug und auch nicht streng
genug ist ja das lieferkettengesetz das
bedeutet einfach dass eben nicht alles
freiwillig sein kann sondern dass es
bestimmte Verpflichtungen eben gibt und
davor so einem Gesetz sind dann aber
auch alle Unternehmen wiederum gleich
ein Gesetz von dem sie seine Auto dazu
bekennen wir uns eindeutig das heißt sie
haben die ganze Lieferkette haben sie
unter Kontrolle sie wissen ganz genau
sie fertigen vor allen Dingen in
Südostasien
Textilien wir fertigen sehr stark in
Südostasien wobei wir seit vielen Jahren
darauf achten dass viel über
unabhängiger von China werden so dass
wir Vietnam Bangladesch Pakistan Türkei
aber auch stark fertigen ist das heißt
also von derselben wir haben auch
bereits vor Jahren angefangen dass wir
in Afrika Produktion unterstützen und
aufbauen weil wir da ja auch die
Kosmetik in Afrika haben hierbei gesagt
es gibt auch bio-kosmet in Afrika haben
wir auch und wir sind auch dabei auch
die traditionelle Afrika durch
biopestitute
nein das ist genau was was unsere
Zielsetzung war dass wir gesagt haben
wir wollen zum generellen
baumwoll-marktpreis wollen wir
letztendlich die Baumwolle anbieten mit
Anbietern die die T-Shirts für 2 € Jeans
für zwei Euro oder Ähnliches anbieten
das also solche Produkte können doch
nicht ernsthaft im Sinne eines
lieferkettengesetzes so sein dass die am
anderen Ende der Kette noch wirklich was
davon haben sind sie auch sicherlich
nicht und solche Produkte würden wir
auch nicht anbieten also von der Seite
sagen wir auch wir wollen jetzt keine
discount Billigprodukte die man drei
vier Mal anziehen und der Werk wirft das
günstig
bei ihnen was kostet das wissen sie das
ungefähr im Kopf also ich schätze das
jetzt wahrscheinlich fünf sechs Euro
kosten wird
ja weil wir eben a von der Qualität her
eigentlich T-Shirt nur anbieten wenn man
es wirklich auch längere Zeit tragen
kann und nicht dass es ihm so leicht und
so dünn ist und dann eventuell doch
vielleicht ins fettshops gefertigt das
wirklich ist
das heißt also in letzte in kleinen
Fabriken wo Niedriglöhne ausbeuterisch
produziert wird mit niedrigen produziert
wird das passiert natürlich nach wie vor
immer wieder solche Dinge machen wir
nicht was ich nicht sagen will dass das
jetzt in dem Fall dort gemacht wird aber
wie gesagt die Gefahr ist natürlich
dabei solchen Preisen sondern wir sagen
es muss zumindest mit diesen Umwelt und
und sozialstandes verbunden sein
das kontrollieren wir auch auditieren
wir auch haben unsere social Office auch
in den Ländern und es muss eine Qualität
haben dass man über längere Zeit ist
auch tragen kann denn was wichtig ist
wir müssen weg von der Werk
werftgesellschaft
und deswegen ist es wichtig dass wie
gesagt solche Produkte auch länger
halten und wenn wir in andere Bereiche
hineingehen dass ihre reparaturfähig
sind recyclingfähig sind okay aber sie
leben doch in gewisser Weise davon dass
Menschen Dinge konsumieren und auch
wegwerfen und immer mehr und immer mehr
und immer mehr wir sind doch wir sind
doch eine sozusagen eine eine
bedarfsweckungsgesellschaft geworden
also so viele Menschen haben Dinge die
sie eigentlich gar nicht haben wollten
aber dann das Gefühl kriegen durch
Marketing durch Werbung acht brauche ich
eigentlich doch davon lebt doch das
ganze System naja ich würde sagen wir
wollen nicht davon leben dass man
schlecht Produkte hat die man häufig
ersetzen muss das ist nicht unser
Zielsetzung sondern wir wollen im Grunde
wollen wir qualitatives Wachstum haben
das heißt dass wir immer bessere
Produkte anbieten und auch Geräte die im
reparaturfähig sind recyclingfähig sind
was wir natürlich dann auch darstellen
das ist eigentlich unser Ziel dass wir
also über besser Qualität unser Wachstum
machen aber nicht wenn sie sagen Geräte
die man reparieren kann zum Beispiel
dieses dieses EU diese eu-idee
[Musik]
gibt die Initiative die jetzt wohl auch
gesetzt werden soll halt die für absolut
richtig aber warum warum brauchen wir so
lange um sowas endlich mal umzusetzen
das Thema heute morgen wieder mit meiner
Zahnbürste kaputt muss den Akku wechseln
kannst den ganz ganz Ding kannst du
wegschmeißen viele Jahre auch bei Handy
so genau dass sie der Akku nicht
wechseln können und das fand ich also
auch immer eine Katastrophe jetzt ist er
da Bewegung reingekommen aber genau das
muss verhindert werden und wenn das auf
freiwilliger Basis nicht erfolgt dann
müssen leider im Gesetz zu kommen das
heißt Freiwilligkeit funktioniert ganz
offensichtlich an dem Punkt nicht
von der anderen Seite noch mal kommen
und Herr Otto findet sich ja auch in
dieser neuen Wirklichkeit die da lautet
also wir haben gerade gehört man startet
sozusagen als sympathischer kleiner
kleines Versandhaus für Schuhe erstmal
ja nach dem Krieg und dann beginnt diese
unglaubliche Erfolgsgeschichte und
plötzlich findest du dich wieder in
einer Welt in der aber die
Nachhaltigkeit die sie beschreiben das
Dinge länger halten sollen dass sie
besser sind dass wir sie nicht wegwerfen
es ist ja das krasse Gegenteil davon was
wir gerade erleben Sie haben es gerade
beschrieben modezyklen in zwei Wochen
neue Kollektionen raus und wieder weg
raus und wieder weg Menschen die voller
Tüten durch Einkaufsstraßen gehen und
wenn Sie noch mehr Hände hätten würden
sie noch mehr töten tragen das ist doch
unser Wirklichkeit das heißt
worüber müssen wir den Wahrheit reden
müssen wir irgendwann eine
verzichtsdebatte führen müssen wir
irgendwann mal darüber nachdenken ob wir
statt immer mehr mit weniger
zurechtkommen
Frage an Sie beide und dann bin ich
gespannt was der Ökonom sagt also ich
finde Verzicht ist so ein sehr
vergiftetes Wort weil das erste Mal ist
ja weil das erstens individuell benutzt
wird also der einzelne soll verzichten
und der Einzelne
kann auch viele Dinge gar nicht
verzichten und wenn er verzichten würde
hat das gar nicht den Markteinfluss den
es haben sollte dann wird es nicht
automatisch weniger hergestellt oder
schädliches wird subventioniert wenn
beispielsweise die Flugindustrie die
ohne Subventionen gar nicht überleben
könnte dass das also ich glaube die die
die die Idee ist so einfach und zum
anderen finde ich verzichtet hat ist
deswegen vergiftetes Wort weil das
sozusagen im Kampfbegriff geworden weil
man Menschen damit Angst macht weil man
und das finde ich ganz ganz erstaunlich
da ist gerade auch vor dem Wahlkampf vor
dem letzten wahnsinnig Politik damit
gemacht worden mit Öko Diktatur und und
was da gelungen ist und das hat sehr
verfangen und das finde ich wirklich
beängstigend und und auch gefährlich ist
dass man die Vorstellung wie wir unsere
Lebensgrundlagen schützen weil darum
geht's ja wir nächsten Jahr um unsere
leb unter aller Lebensgrundlagen wie wir
unsere Lebensgrundlagen und unsere
Zukunft schützen ist letztlich
umgedeutet worden zu einer Bedrohung für
Wohlstand zu zu einer
Freiheitseinschränkung zu der zu was
aggressiven und das ist ja eine total
fatale Täter opferumkehr und natürlich
wird das gerne von von
gesellschaftlichen Kräften
hervorgebracht die Interesse haben ihre
eigenen privileginnen Privilegien zu
erhalten und uns da soziale Stockholm
Syndrom mäßig versuchen auf ihre Seite
zu ziehen und gefährlich ist es nur ist
es vor allem eben deswegen weil wir ja
darüber reden müssen als Gesellschaft
wie wir anders zusammen leben weil
diesen Überkonsum da müssen wir auf die
Produktion sehr viel mehr schauen als
auf den Konsum weil wenn das Zeug in den
Läden liegt ja nun dann wird es halt
entweder gekauft oder wird
weggeschmissen wenn es nicht gekauft
wird dann muss man ja ganz ehrlich sein
aber es behindert einfach es verstellt
einfach so den Blick was anderes möglich
wäre weil tatsächlich verzichten wir ja
schon auf ganz viel wir verzichten auf
ein gutes Gefühl in Hinblick auf unsere
Zukunft und die Zukunft von unseren
Kindern und Enkeln wir verzichten auf
Gerechtigkeit wir verzichten auf gute
Luft auf den wir verzichten auf gerechte
Bildung Gesundheitsversorgung und all
diese Dinge die wirklich wichtig sind
verzichten wir ja schon gezwungenermaßen
und das verstellt einfach so ein
bisschen den Blick was alles möglich
wäre wenn man das nicht einfach immer
nur als Einschränkung sehen würde
welches Wort würden sie benutzen wenn
Sie das böse Wort verzichten nicht sagen
wollen wir müssen darüber sprechen und
da gibt es keinen Reisbrett Plan den
habe ich auch nicht und Gott sei Dank
hat den auch keiner wie wir von diesem
wachstumsdiktat wegkommen wie wir von
diesem
Konsumzwang wegkommen hin dazu dass
Ressourcen gerecht verteilt werden
können also ich finde Gerechtigkeit ist
da ganz ganz wichtig ökologische und
soziale Gerechtigkeit dass man gar nicht
trennen kann also wie kommen wir da weg
welche Ideen gibt's da davon wegzukommen
welche Alternativen gibt es da schon und
es gibt ja Alternativen in der
Landwirtschaft Verkehr
Energieversorgung und zu fragen wer ist
es und dafür gibt es ja teilweise
wirklich große gesellschaftliche
Mehrheiten was ich sehr beruhigend finde
fünf Verkehrswende für eine ökologisch
und sozialgerechte Landwirtschaft ganz
große Mehrheiten sondern eher zu fragen
wer blockiert denn diese Veränderung
weil dann können wir als wissen wir als
Gesellschaft natürlich auch wogegen wir
uns wenden können und wir müssen uns ja
und das ist ja erschüttern und traurig
und auch wirklich schmerzhaft genug wir
müssen uns ja diese Realität stellen
dass wir bald in einer anderen Welt
leben werden in der
indem wir über ganz andere Dinge
sprechen werden müssen als ob wir jetzt
genügend Konsum betreiben können sondern
es geht um Lebensgrundlagen um Wasser
und so weiter
ihre Generation wie wie schaut die auf
dieses Thema auf das Thema würden sie
das Wort verzichte in den Mund nehmen
selbst Christian lindert letztens Wort
Verzicht positiv in den Mund genommen da
ging es dann um die Schuldenbremse weil
das ist dann nämlich okay weil für mich
so lieben
da muss dann auch mal verzichtet werden
ich glaube was klar ist es wenn Menschen
aus meiner Generation oder noch jünger
in die Zukunft schauen dann ist klar wir
verzichten so oder so auf unglaublich
viele Dinge die wir als
Gesamtgesellschaft immer für gesetzt
gesehen haben wir leben ja in dieser
Erzählung wo uns immer erzählt wird der
Wohlstand wächst und wächst und wächst
und es geht uns allen besser weil wir
haben Handys und wir haben mehr Autos
und alles wird besser und wir haben
jetzt auch die Bananen irgendwie aus
ganz weit weg
aber gleichzeitig ist klar der Wohlstand
schrumpft nicht weil wir irgendwie die
Klimakrise eindämmen wollen sondern er
schrumpft in Folge der Klimakrise die
Klimakrise ist unser größtes
wohlstandsrisiko was wir gerade haben
wenn wir uns anschauen
schauen wir uns an eine Person mein
alter erbt irgendwie den Hof ihrer
Eltern belant wird werden und muss sich
jetzt fragen kann ich überhaupt noch
Landwirt werden in Deutschland weil ich
bekommen keine Versicherung die für die
Ernteausfälle die vielleicht durch den
nächsten Sommer und wir haben jetzt
mehreren Folge erlebt kommen wird sich
das überhaupt noch rentieren kann ich
damit in Zukunft haben oder muss ich
einen anderen Job wählen eine Person
muss ich fragen will ich da noch wohnen
kann man da noch wohnen wenn irgendwie
klar ist wir werden mehreren
Klimakrise extreme Wetter extreme
erleben und es bezieht sich nicht nur
auf die Klimakrise das sehen wir auch
beispielsweise so wenn wir uns Einkommen
Chancen anschauen für wir sind die erste
Generation also meine Generation die
schlechtere Chancen als ihre Eltern hat
und wo sehr sehr wahrscheinlich ist für
viele trotz eigentlich erst mal formell
besserer Bildung eine ähnliches wohl das
Niveau wenn man sich jetzt sozusagen
Einkommen im Vergleich zu wie teuer sind
Wohnungen wie teuer sind viele andere
also sozusagen Gegenstände alltäglichen
Lebens da sozusagen auf ein ähnliches
Niveau zu kommen dass es für viele
Menschen aus meiner Generation
tatsächlich unwahrscheinlicher und da
sehen wir das dreht sich zum ersten Mal
um wir erleben Menschen die tatsächlich
aufgrund der Klimakrise sterben weil es
so heiß ist im Sommer und das alles sind
Dinge wo wir jetzt gerade schon erleben
der das wohlstandsrisiko sind nicht die
politischen Maßnahmen die wir treffen um
zu sagen wir wollen Einkommen gerech
dafür teilen wenn man Vermögen gerechter
verteilen wir wollen die Klimakrise
einnehmen
genau dieser Profit Drang dieser Zwang
zu Profit Maximierung zu einer
angeblichen Wirtschaftswachstum was
angeblich Dinge besser macht aber was
tatsächlich erstmal in sich gar nichts
besser macht sondern die Welt
ungerechter und tatsächlich leben
Chancen für mich und kommende Generation
verschlechtert noch mal konkret also
wenn sie
spannend wird ja immer wenn es ganz
konkret wird ja also wenn man sagt wir
müssen dann jetzt irgendwann die großen
Dinge mal aus dem Sack holen und jetzt
wird verzichtet
das heißt gibt es dann einen Kontingent
für was man sich Mallorca Flüge zum
Beispiel du sagst du hattest schon in
diesem Jahr dreimal 54 nicht geben als
Beispiel jetzt also es gibt Dinge die
werden sich auch über den Marktregeln
das sind so Dinge die jetzt nicht zu
einer gesellschaftlichen Grundversorgung
zählen und im Bereich Flugindustrie das
hat auch Frau hat man gerade
angesprochenen riesige Subventionen wenn
man einmal tatsächlich die Kosten von
was kostet fliegen tatsächlich ein Preis
dann ist klar man wird nicht mehr für 9
oder 19 und auch nicht 29 € nach
Mallorca fliegen können und das ist auch
okay wir haben alle in der
corona-pandemie plötzlich erlebt oh
Leute finden wandern wieder ganz toll
weil das ist auch tatsächlich ganz schön
und ich glaube da werden wir eine
Verschiebung erleben ne qualitative
Verschiebung wir brauchen aber natürlich
gerade wenn wir uns ankommen anschauen
dass viele der Vorschläge wie können wir
in den marktwirtschaftlichen System die
Klimakrise einnehmen natürlich über
magmechanismen gehen dass wir sagen wir
besteuern CO2 es gibt einen Preis für
CO2 auch für andere Treibhausgase dann
müssen wir auch Einkommen gerechter
verteilen dann kann es nicht sein dass
es Millionen Menschen in Deutschland
gibt die unter der Armutsgrenze leben
die oder die armutsgefährdet sind das
kann nicht sein sondern da müssen wir
dann auch wieder staatlich Eingreifen
das Glas es gibt
Existenzminimum und das muss für alle
Gesellschaft sein niemand darf frieren
müssen weil Energiepreise höher werden
weil eben CO2 zu teuer ist
auszustoßen und gleichzeitig auch zu
sagen was sind denn gesellschaftliche
Bereiche die für uns als Gesellschaft
wichtig sind Beispiel Wärmeversorgung
Energieversorgung wollen wir die
wirklich ein paar profitorientierten
Unternehmen überlassen die dann im Fall
von der Energiekrise wie jetzt gerade
Milliarden Gewinne machen wo wir
politisch nicht mal eingreifen können
weil ja dann wollte man über
Gewinnsteuer machen aber irgendwie war
es dann doch wusste man nicht so genau
wie man es umsetzen sondern hat man es
doch wieder so halb vergessen bei einem
gut was für uns alle existenziell
wichtig ist weil wir sind uns ja
gesellschaftlich einig niemand soll in
einer kalten dunklen Wohnung sitzen und
da auch zu sagen das sind Bereiche die
müssen wir gesellschaftlich organisieren
die müssen staatlich organisiert sein
und nicht irgendwie Profit maximiert von
ein paar wenigen Großkonzern gemacht
werden